what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
7 update video a short video was
released by HBO which featured the
costume designer Michelle Clapton in all
the various costumes she has made over
the course of the Game of Thrones series
but most importantly the costume she has
made for the seventh season of Game of
Thrones and I must say the costume she
has made over the years of some of the
best I've ever seen on TV or film but
during this 3 minute video they released
they were also showing some behind the
scenes shots of the actors as they were
in between filming some scenes they only
showed each scene for about 1 or 2
seconds each but there was one
particular scene that gave away a pretty
big plot point for next season as they
were showing the brief scene of Cersei
Lannister if you pause the video at the
right moment you can see that there are
some other characters down in this
dungeon looking room as well off in the
back you can see the mountain with his
helmet off but if you look over here to
the right you can see another character
in Chains and that is without a doubt a
Laureus and a few months ago there were
some leaked photos online of a scene
taking place and what was most likely
King's Landing in these scenes you can
see you're on Greyjoy on horseback with
several different prisoners he has
chained up with him as he is escorting
them somewhere I've always assumed urine
was taking them to Cersei Lannister as
sort of like an offering to strike an
alliance with her you can see the city
watch in these photos too but we weren't
able to confirm it just yet we still
wasn't exactly sure what he was going to
be doing with these prisoners you can
see that he has you're a Greyjoy
glorious an anti insane with him and we
all know that Cersei would love to get
her hands on these sand snakes
especially al aureus and who killed her
daughter at the end of season 5 now we
can 100% confirm that these prisoners
will be in the custody of Cersei
Lannister and by the looks of this room
it doesn't look like this is going to be
a pleasant scene I can't say exactly
what room they are in but this does
appear to be some type of dungeon or
basement and considering the fact that
the mountain is going to be in this
scene as well means bad news for the
sand snakes and possibly even Yara
Greyjoy
we can't see your in this scene but you
can see that there are at least two
prisoners down there a Laureus chain
does link to someone else
most likely tyene sand and I'm sure Yara
is down here too but I can't confirm
that but now I definitely think that was
your
in the throne room with Cersei Lannister
in the trailer you can see their short
hair just like your own has his hair now
and you can see he is dressed in all
black like you're honest here this has
to be the scene when your own arrives in
King's Landing with his prisoners and he
hands them over to Cersei most likely as
part of a deal to form an alliance with
each other that would definitely explain
two faiths Cersei and Jaime making the
trailer when they both look very pissed
off just the sight of a laureates face
alone must make them furious knowing
that she poisoned their daughter
I did not expect Cersei to show them any
kind of mercy but I'll put the link to
the full video down in this description
in case any of you want to watch the
entire video
I do believe HBO just officially
released it on their YouTube channel as
well so you can go watch it there also
but comment below and let me know what
you think now that this is confirmed
what do you think Cersei and/or the
mountain will do to these prisoners down
here in this dark and damp looking room
I don't think it's going to go over too
well for them but thanks for stopping by
to watch this quick update video I'll
see you all down in the comment section
bye